you ever thought about turning your
phone into a gameboy yeah sure there are
several ways to do that but nothing
quite like hi Perkins smart boy let's
run through some of the basics it's an
attachment for Android based phones that
connects via USB see it's specifically
designed for samsung smartphones but any
Android device that fits into this USB
port will work for example I'm using the
razor phone here the smart boy reads
original Game Boy and Game Boy Color
cartridges the bottom half resembles the
original Gameboy controls and the top
half of your phone screen displays the
game the smart boys been out for a while
and goes for fifty US dollars or sixty
British pounds let's get into how this
thing actually works first you need to
download the smart boy app from hyper
akin on the Google Play Store to get it
working then you need to download a
launching app hypercam recommends my old
boy which is free on the Google Play
Store now you're ready to snap your
phone into their device once you do the
smart boy app will launch itself now you
insert a Game Boy cartridge and the app
will load the game onto your phone last
thing you got to do is find the hyper
akin folder within the launch app so
select it and bam the game is up and
running the main question here is if
it's any good in terms of running Game
Boy games the pair of apps work well
together
games are upscale to fit the phone's
resolution and they look great based on
my time using the smart boy I didn't run
into any perceivable input lag or
game-breaking bugs however you may run
into trouble navigating these
applications since the device obscures
half the phone screen you can pull out
your phone at any time to access menus
and games will still run since all the
data has been temporarily dumped into
the app but you have to relaunch the
apps to continue playing after snapping
your phone back into the smart boy
thankfully the game state remains
untouched the smart boy device itself is
ergonomically similar to the original
Game Boy holding this thing very much
feels the same but the buttons and d-pad
have a slightly improved tactile
response over the original Gameboy the
smart boy is a bit bulky though and it
is an exactly ideal to take on the go by
no means is it fragile but it does have
a slight hollow or flimsy feel if you
have an Android phone in physical
Gameboy cartridges in working condition
that you really want to play the smart
boy is a good way to go about that in a
world where there are so many ways to
play old games hybrid and smart boy
offers an authentic experience that
meshes well with modern tech even if
it's not the most practical approach
we're covering a lot of retro gaming
hardware here at GameSpot so stick
around for all that good stuff thanks
for watching
[Music]